isa ray just taught me to
be true to my point of view and
get it out there no matter what no
matter how many rejections you get no
matter how many no's you get
how did you meet issa ray
so i met issa rae on twitter
this was
like 10
plus a couple months year ago
10 years plus a couple months ago and
i had just left facebook because i just
thought facebook was so dramatic and
there was just too much going on with
having your elementary school friends on
there with your middle school friends
with your high school friends with your
college friends with your family i was
like i need to like not be part of this
chatter so i left facebook before it was
even cool to leave facebook
and as i left it i said to myself i was
panicking a little bit and i said well i
need some kind of social media what's it
gonna be and then i saw that twitter was
happening and not happening like
today but it was it was a newish
platform so i was like okay i'm gonna
make a twitter
and then i got on twitter and i started
following this
this person joshua at film tv diversity
and he would tweet out
different writers and producers and
directors and creators to follow so i
would just click follow on every single
one of them because i didn't know what i
was doing on twitter and and there was
always really great advice coming from
twitter
from the people i follow in terms of
filmmaking
and then
she had tweeted out
follow issa rae she makes web series and
i said great followed her she followed
me right back
and then a couple days later she
tweeted out i'm looking for a mixed
looking girl to play my best friend in
my next web series
and i dm'ed her and i said hey i'm not
mixed but
this is what i look like here's a
picture of me
can i audition anyway and she said yeah
of course come on down
and she gave me the address and i pull
up to the house this is a house in a
nice neighborhood but regardless a house
and for any actors watching out there i
don't recommend you go to a house for an
audition that's super shady
you want to drive away
i did not drive away
i
i was about to drive away but then i saw
issa come out and she was talking on her
cell phone and i was like oh it's fine
it's a girl it's a woman still not the
right attitude to have
so i went into the house did the
audition it was super chill i was there
for about five minutes and then i left
and then a couple hours later she said
you booked the roll
and i said okay
cool and then a couple weeks later
i
went to issa's dad's doctor's office in
inglewood which where we would be
shooting awkward black girl and we just
shot a very quick 20-minute hallway
scene that i believe is in episode three
of awkward black girl where my character
is introduced and it was just me isa and
her brother and her brother was running
the camera and the sound was definitely
attached to the microphone was attached
to the camera so there was no separate
sound system we had to come hair and
makeup ready
and uh like i said it took 20 minutes
and then she isa said thank you so much
and then i left and
i asked myself what did i get myself
into what is this web series
like nobody knew what web series was at
the time
and
that's how i met issa rae
that's a great story
you'd been acting what eight years prior
to doing awkward black girl well i've i
would say i've been acting
since i was like
five or six just from back home just
putting on my own shows putting on my
own performances and then
doing plays in elementary middle school
and then doing
musicals and being in the chorus in
middle school and high school and so
i've been acting i would say pretty much
my whole life
yeah you did the web series for free
correct yes i did and that's an
interesting decision which i think at
the time i was doing a lot of stuff for
free so like i said i was auditioning
for
afi films i was auditioning for usc
films and ucla films and most of the
time those films didn't even get
finished and and that was the
tragedy of it all because i didn't mind
doing
working for free because it was always
really fun
but
i believe that a lot of the time the
filmmakers came up against wanting their
project to be perfect
and then going through the
post-production
process and realizing that it wasn't
what they had envisioned and then
completely throwing it out and i believe
that is
the wrong attitude to have as a
filmmaker as a creator i truly believe
that you should
finish stuff
and also put it out there and also
submit it to festivals and even if it's
not what you thought it was going to be
it could still be accepted as something
else and so that's the exciting part of
it even if you have
something that may not have the best
production quality or the best acting or
the best sound
just put it out there and guess what
you're gonna
learn from that mistake
and you're not gonna make that mistake
again and your next thing or project
will be
ten times better oh and then you just
keep working you just gotta keep
making stuff and putting it out and then
make the next thing so something that i
like to point out is if you watch the
first two or so episodes of awkward
black girl on youtube
the production quality isn't great the
sound isn't great
but there's something there there's
something there that makes you keep
coming back and then you notice
as
those season one episodes go on
oh they i think they got lighting i
think they might have gotten a
microphone they might have gotten a
sound person
oh their their
wardrobe looks a little bit better
so i love
awkward black girl in that it it is on
youtube and you can watch the
progression of how it just keeps getting
better and better and and i think
that was you know when i was doing free
projects um i was just excited to be
meeting people and working with new
people and
once again just be surrounded by
creativity
what do you think made that show so
popular
what made awkward black girl popular was
that it reached an audience that was
being ignored by hollywood
and it was
black women
that
were not used to seeing themselves on
screen
and that's that's what was really
exciting about being a part of that
journey and watching as the episodes
came out one by one
watching
the
the view count keep growing and it
turned into a snowball and and we were
getting comments we were getting dms we
were getting
uh messages from people oh my god i've
never seen myself on screen before this
is me
or do you have a camera in my home
are you watching my life are you
watching my relationships are you
watching my friendships and that was the
most exciting part of it because
like i said hollywood has a way of
taking a group of people and
making
the same story about them over and over
and over again and
and this was such a specific story from
a specific point of view that had never
been told before that had never been on
screen
and
that was that was part of
why it became the success that it became
um
season one episode seven
after we ended that season we did a
kickstarter
and we were looking for thirty thousand
dollars to make the last i believe
four or five episodes
and
we didn't know how much money we were
going to raise and
you know even the no i remember we were
having we were all kind of hanging out
talking about oh how much should we ask
for should we ask for
10 000 should we ask for 12 15 and
they decided on 30 and we ended up
making 54 000
and
[Music]
once again that was proof that there
were people out there
that needed to see this that wanted to
see this and wanted to see how the
season was going to end what was going
to happen with white jay and jay
and what was going to happen with jay at
work and with her friends
and so
that's what was really fun and exciting
to see that
oh
there
is the possibility of creating something
that appeals to a certain group of
people that have never seen themselves
on screen before so that's what
makes me so excited about creating my
work
sure and you think too because the
characters were it just wasn't about
a stereotype it was about
these are real people not okay this
person fits this stereotype or
demographic for this one role we need
this like
character relief kind of thing
yeah i think it was successful because
each character was a well-rounded
individual and
a lot of the time
the
the audience when they would message us
they would be like oh my best friend is
exactly like that or the guy that i'm
dating is exactly like that so so we
were tapping into something real and
and
non-stereotypical for sure
what did issa rae teach you about the
business what did you learn just by
watching her
isa ray just taught me to
be true to my point of view and
get it out there no matter what no
matter how many rejections you get no
matter how many no's you get
every person has a unique story to tell
and
each story is important and
generally not
out there yet and there are audiences
today that are not being served by
what hollywood is offering so
i'm just excited to fill that void of
content
how did you end up on felicia day as the
guild after that
oh
i don't get asked about the guild too
much so this is exciting okay so
i believe it was season two of awkward
black girl
the guild was also
i believe one of the only other web
series that had been happening at the
same time so we were aware of the guild
um the awkward black girl scott squad
was aware of the guild and
and i i believe it was just an audition
so i had gotten an email
through my reps oh felicia day's web
series they're casting for certain roles
in their sixth and last season
and would you be down to audition
and
i had known of felicia day i had not
been watching the guild but but i kind
of crash coursed it
when i went in for the audition and and
it was really cool because as soon as i
walked in it felt like oh we're we're
like
the two web series that are happening
right now this is really exciting and
they're both
created by women which was also an
exciting thing
and so i went in and i auditioned it was
really fun and i also booked that job
and
that was
awesome to do i believe it was happening
at the same time when we were shooting
awkward black girls season two so i was
working on both of them at the same time
and
just had a blast and felicia's great and
it was it was it was really awesome to
watch because they they were in their
sixth season so to watch to go from one
web series to another that was so much
ahead like like the
there were extras and there were
big sets and and it was it was fun it
was fun to be a part of that and to see
where a web series could go
if it went on for a couple more seasons
i'm curious why you didn't do definition
please as a web series did you feel like
it was better served as a feature or or
would you want to continue it on
through
many seasons
because you could go many places with
things yeah yeah definition please to me
was always a feature and i'm not quite
sure why i decided on that i i have
projects that are specifically tv
projects that are specifically film
and and for definition please i i didn't
even really
think of the idea until about 2015 when
i was
in my ucb sketch writing class and i
wrote a four-page sketch about
spelling bee winners
which served as the basic premise for
definition please and
then i had started going to sundance in
and that really inspired me to
create a film to be honest and and this
was also post cowboy and indian where i
had made a short film
and once again it was really fun taking
it around to film festivals so for me
definition please
was never a web series and it was always
a feature film
you think it could be
at some point
i think my journey with definition
please is over
okay
i want to see like high school reunions
different things you know right right
different dramas yeah yeah i think i
think there is a world that i created
that could it could keep going and
people want to know what happens after
monica moves to cleveland
but i i truly believe that once i'm done
with the story i'm pretty much finished
with the story and and and i have
10 or so other projects that i'd love to
get off the ground and shoot so
i'm excited to move on to the next thing
were you protective of monica as a
character you know how they they write
like you know have horrible things
happen to your character i realize
you know you weren't making that exact
kind of film even though there were
family dramas but was it hard to let
monica go
no
i i have a way of detaching from
my stories and characters and so
i want them to
be real and be grounded and pursue the
path that their character would take and
and i don't take it personally as a
writer or a filmmaker and so i'm always
excited i think with monica i love that
she is
unlikable in the beginning of the film
and and you
are kind of trying to figure out why
she's so mean to her brother who seems
really nice
and and and i love writing flawed
characters as well so so it was just fun
to write a character that
had all these different things going on
and wasn't fully good or fully bad